it's great to be joined today by Kara
brown McCormack who's the co-founder of
the committee for ranked choice voting
in Maine which had a big big success
when it comes to the the fight for
ranked choice voting kara great to talk
to you today it's great to talk to you
David thanks so much for having me so we
recently talked to fair vote about what
ranked choice voting is different
methods of installing ranked choice
voting how votes can be tabulated so we
have sort of a sense of how it works
what I'd like to talk about with you to
begin with is how did this initiative in
Maine start in other words how did this
activism become successful activism
well we started in Maine with about four
years ago with about five people and
what we did is we filled out a piece of
paper and turned it in to the Secretary
of State with a copy of the law that we
wanted to put forward which was a ranked
choice voting law for all federal and
state offices in the state of Maine we
by that action were able to get the
Secretary of State to approve a petition
and we spent about a year with
volunteers gathering 75,000 signatures
we needed sixty 1123 signatures which
represents 10% of the people who voted
in the last election or in that case it
would have been in the 2012 election and
we then had a campaign a year-long
campaign and in November of 2016 we won
ranked choice voting in Maine with the
second largest vote in the history of
citizens initiatives in Maine so to kind
of outline the process in its pieces
first you sort of drafted what the law
would look like once that was sort of
okayed conceptually at that point you
needed signatures from Maine residents
in order to get it on the ballot as a
referendum question as a as a citizen
initiated referendum question exactly
ultimately voted on in 2016 and
past it wasn't a huge margin it was 52
to 48 but that made it the law and how
soon after that did it go into effect so
it went into effect on January 7th of
2017 that's when it became the law of
the state of Maine and can then I'm
sorry yeah go ahead well I'm just gonna
say and then about four days later we
realized that the Republican state
Senate President was going to begin the
process of repealing the citizens
initiative in the legislature because a
citizen's law doesn't have any more
weight than a law that's created by the
legislature so it's not like just
because it was a citizen's initiative
and we passed it into law with you know
the vote of the people that it was
gold-plated in anyway it just it's just
a law than like any other law and so we
wrongly assumed that we were done and
what happened over the next ten months
is really really interesting we fought
off one repeal attempt in the
legislature at the end of June of 2017
and the government was even shut down
and repealing rank-choice voting was one
of the conditions that the governor of
Maine put on his list of conditions for
reopening up the government
it didn't get repealed then but then on
October 23rd of 2017 in a special
session a late-night session of the
legislature that was called specifically
for this purpose the legislature I would
say you know most Republicans and some
Democrats combined to repeal the
citizen's initiative what were the
reasons that they cited for their
opposition to this they you know
different people had different reasons
for for opposing ranked choice voting
there the Secretary of State said that
it was too costly that it was too
confusing people said things like well
the people didn't really know
they were voting for or it's a lot of
people said it was unconstitutional
there was there were there were many
many objections from the political
establishment in Maine and they the
legislature had you know fundamentally
altered or repealed all of the citizens
initiatives that we passed in November
of 2016 so rank-choice voting wasn't
alone in in that but it was the first
time I think that a citizen's initiative
had been in the history of me and that a
citizen's initiative had been sort of on
its you know in its whole repeal so
what's next for the for the movement I
mean where do things stand now and what
is it that we should be looking to do
well this is really interesting so what
happened on October 23rd was that they
repealed it but that night we watched
them from the gallery repeal the law and
we launched that night on October 23rd
2017 what's called a people's veto so we
have in our Constitution something
besides just a citizen's initiative we
can also take away from the legislature
something that we deem repellant as a
people so in 88 days in the middle of
last winter we collected another sixty
1123 signatures and we turned them in to
the Secretary of State on February 2nd
of 2018 and we froze our original law in
place by that action and so rank-choice
voting was implemented and used for the
first time in Maine on June 12th of 2018
and then we voted on that same day this
time we won by an 8% margin to keep
rank-choice voting so we used it again
in November this past November election
for the first time ever in the United
States of America rank-choice voting was
used for federal offices in a general
election statewide in the state of Maine
so it wasn't over when they repealed
that it actually just made us sort of
stronger and more resilient can you talk
a little bit about whether there are
races do we even know whether there are
races that would have
turned out differently if ranked choice
voting were not in place in other words
would some of the recent races voted on
under rank choice would would the
results have been different if
first-past-the-post were still in place
well I can tell you that in in the
second congressional district of Maine
we only have two Congress people from
the state of Maine we're a small state
and in the second congressional district
ranked choice voting was used so the
Republican incumbent congressman Bruce
Poliquin received 46% of the vote and
the Democratic challenger Jared golden
also received 46% of the vote and then
two independents ran in that race and
they both got about twelve percent of
the vote all together and so I'm sorry
they both split the rest of the rest of
that vote and so in the first round of
counting the incumbent congressman had a
you know margin on the
first-past-the-post he he got the most
first choice votes but once the ranked
choice voting kicked in
Jared golden emerged the winner and will
be sworn into Congress at the beginning
of next year absolutely amazing so in
other words you by virtue of having rank
choice voting in that race
individuals who felt more aligned with
one of the third party candidates could
vote for those third party candidates to
show support but they were not
ultimately helping to elect the person
with whom they most disagreed because on
the second tally their votes transferred
to the eventual winner yes you totally
understand so the people who were into
voting for the independence more of them
chose Jared gold in the Democrat as
their second choice then Bruce Poliquin
and so Jared golden emerged with more
than 50% of the vote in the first in the
second round of counting in the
tabulation and he was elected with a
majority of the vote and with the
broadest
you know the broadest number of people
and that's how rank-choice voting is
meant to work you can vote for the
person that you like the most without
fear of electing the person that you
like the least
and the candidate who wins is elected
with the majority of the people and we
hope will govern in a different in a
different way and on behalf of the
broadest number of his or her
constituents are you at all concerned
about the possibility of main
rank-choice voting being overturned in
some other way the Maine Supreme Court
questions of constitutionality anything
like that so we're actually in court
right now in the United States District
Court Poliquin when he didn't win the
election went took us to court and said
that the election should be thrown out
that it was an illegal election that the
federal court should immediately declare
him the winner and throw out there was
you know he wanted to stop the counting
and and have the court immediately
declared him the winner and he asked for
a temporary restraining order in federal
court a couple of weeks ago the judge
who was appointed by donald trump just
just over a month ago this was one of
his first cases to be heard he ruled
against bruce poliquin in the temporary
restraining order he said that there
were no constitutional United States
constitutional issues with ranked choice
voting he allowed bruce poliquin lawsuit
to proceed and yesterday we were in
court for another five hours up in
bangor in the US District Court and the
arguments were made by our side and by
poliquin's side and we'll see we the
judge told us that we should have a
final ruling by next week and we expect
that the judge will rule in our favor
and that the people of Maine have a
right under the United States
Constitution to choose the way that we
elect our leaders and we look very much
forward to that decision because
hopefully it will pave the way if others
if other people in other states want to
bring rank-choice voting to their
politics that that Court decision will
help them do it because rank-choice
voting is not unconstitutional
what other B you mentioned other states
are there where else should people be
looking now for the strongest
initiatives to do rank-choice voting at
the state level so I think that that's a
question you know that's sort of yet to
be answered I know that in Massachusetts
and in in Wisconsin there are some
efforts and for sure in the state of
Minnesota Minnesota has ranked choice
voting in both Minneapolis and st. Paul
and there's a fabulous organization
there called fair vote Minnesota and a
woman called gene Massey who's leading
an effort there which I think is very
very strong because they already use it
in two of their biggest cities in the
state and you know the reason why Maine
had such a good chance to get ranked
choice voting although it was a huge
struggle is because we use it in the
city of Portland Maine and so we've used
it in the city of Portland Maine since
2011 so it wasn't a completely foreign
concept to the people here can you talk
a little bit in the last bit of time we
have left
what other policy coupled with rank
choice voting do you think would most
significantly change or improve upon
some of the problems we have in the
United States so would it be rank choice
voting coupled with for example public
financing of Elections would it be
ranked choice voting coupled with a
repeal or undoing of citizens united for
example or I mean really whatever it is
what other policy could build on rank
choice voting to really improve the
democratic process so I think that rank
choice voting is the most stunningly
right idea for the times that we find
ourselves in our politics are polarized
yet we agree on much much more than we
disagree on and so I and I think that if
we were to have rank choice voting in in
our elections that there would be less
of a need to
you know I think that other things will
work themselves out because because of
rank-choice voting but of course
important to get money out of politics
of course you know gerrymandering is is
you know overturning Citizens United
those are things you know that I that I
personally support but I think that
rank-choice voting as a reform will will
necessarily lead to all of the other
reforms because it fix some it fixes
something structural that's beneath
beneath the rest of the politics and
it's sort of it opens things up in a way
it's that's very very powerful it's a
it's a it's a terrific reform we're
really proud of what we did in Maine and
we hope that we pave the way for other
people in other states too to take to
take it on and to run with it and
anybody who's watching you know please
come to our Facebook page the committee
for ranked choice voting and let us know
who you are and and we'll see if we can
we can help you absolutely fantastic
stuff we've been speaking with Kara
Brown McCormick co-founder of the
committee for ranked choice voting in
Maine Kara thank you so much for talking
to me today
thank you David thank you for having me
for getting the word out take care